quand tu te lances dans une entreprise
de fermes comme ce à la grandeur que
celles aux congés échelle humaine faut
que les deux choix est prête à salé les
mains
[Musique]
la canne blanche a présentement 325
canetons deuil nous ici c'est bien-être
animal et on était coresponsable on est
probablement les premiers producteurs à
commercialiser le requin
[Musique]
à chaque matin après avoir sorti les
oiseaux à l'extérieur on vient ramasser
les oeufs à la main
[Musique]
laura maes nos 250 heures chaque matin
de cette manière
j'ai appris à 17 ans j'avais une maladie
dégénérative monte à 50 ans que je serai
complètement veille puis je me dis bon
belgique en train il me reste cinq
belles années à voir mais c'est pas vrai
je vois plus tant que sage et j'irai pas
prendre une marche tout seul même pas
que ma canne blanche c'est une chance
que j'aie daniel pour me montrer
c'est quoi c'est lui a plus d'expérience
de non voyants que deux voyants et ça
n'en vaut même plus que quand j'y suis
mois et demi si je crois que c'est moi
où je suis et mon l'accès s'est fait
confiance
s'il vous plaît d'essayer passe à la
maison mais c'est les experts fin au
scan a tellement de voyants qui déforme
la réalité qui déforme ce qu'il voit un
mois je ne défends pas aux jeunes crient
fait que je peux pas me tromper
[Musique]
ici il faut que je fasse attention parce
que toujours jossic danser entre lot
voies j'en ai un lot j'en ai l'eau cela
ici je sais et j'ai déjà mangé
d'habitude ricard pendant deux ans
je mange pas s'appliquer partout au lieu
de le mettre à quatre pattes comme
j'attends tôt j'ai encore un petit
visuel 20 kg en un défaut que j'ai la
chance de voir comme ça quand tu es
aveugle dans la vie on doit s'adapter
rapidement
écoutez ce qu'on ressentait nous quand
vous travaillez et on écoutait quand un
oiseau qui est amorphe va aller se
cacher votre cash en arrière des portes
d'entrée aux autres les voix sont très
actifs et comme beaucoup rentrent en
d'appui sa gries hadopi ça crie donc
pour moi s'amuse x3o later
[Musique]
c'est un oiseau idéal pour un oiseau qui
marche et qui est qui commet que tu
chantes encore été ses poils attendent
notre illico en latence déplacer puis
pige à 15 beaucoup donc c'est un oiseau
pour aveu si on prend pour le foot pour
être au travail va pas travailler des
oiseaux qui voit le 6 mai et quand
l'insee
moi je me rétracte un parti non pas par
télé on va les amener les oeufs à la
cuisine à l'endroit où ce qu on les
nettoie c'est tout est au vert un an le
dis on va les ramasser a parlé la veille
en fin et les vendre et c'est exactement
je veux rester à petite échelle parce
que mes oiseaux ont besoin de plus c'est
pas vrai que je vais mettre des cas
marin cage mois pour faire une grosse
production d'oeuvres de cannes
l'important moins pour moi vous êtes
parfois club de cannes souhaite faire
découvrir aux gentils
car c'est good bye le monologue de
poutres le jean yves meyer ni plus
crémeux y est plus volumineux dans un
faux plat lui sera pas plus le ton neuf
le avec les gens qui peuplent le bien
est tout gonflé au taux plein chante
toute la place magnifique halle aux
autopsies
le goût est pratiquement arrive enfin
[Musique]
williams et oiseaux il tout ce qui nous
manque le matin soit suggérée du grand
soin suggère de l'eau puis au moins à
part toutes les deux jeunes hommes à
penser aux îles je jouerai jamais de ce
que je dois le faire la vitesse que je
dois le faire mais mon convoi de 35 ans
david un tableau ça l'était toujours
d'essayer d'être aussi vite un moyen
d'essayer que ça paraisse portable wii
vont se mettre à courir ont causé le
zune vont se mettre à se blesser
la seule chose qui peut que qui peuvent
faire une différence est ce que ça
marche ça marche pas c'est l'amour que
toskala pas seulement
c'est tellement une place aux jeux
d'hiver
c'est mieux de les traiter des oiseaux
buvant pèlerins qui s'étendent bédié
[Musique]
royer a personne qui va me sortir de ma
canardière
même si je viens à 23 millions de pagani
y a personne qui va me sortir ce que
vous m'avez vu faire aujourd'hui je dois
le faire l'année prochaine soit le
pendant deux ans puis je veux le faire
jusqu'à temps que la santé me le permet
ce que j'aimerais par exemple c'est qu'à
la canne blanche et des petits bébés
partout que l'on puisse guider des gens
des gens qui ont eu des difficultés à
l'emploi qui pourrait se séparera les
valoriser fierté a laissé s'accomplir
comme nous aurons fait le plein et puis
travailler c'est même pas un travail
c'est même pas un travail ce poste c'est
vraiment trop jeune pour être réparé
[Musique]